people don't realize the impact they
have and just what a kind word
can do for someone yeah that person
could be waiting to hang on to that
that kindness that you gave them
and it could lift them up to do things
you'll never know i mean if
if if if we all look back and see who
who gave us that that kept us going when
we were thinking about maybe it's over
you know maybe who was it who was who
was well my wife was one when i when i
got out of here she
she saw you at your lows too well she
saw me when i was a broke dick dude and
and she literally got on stage with me
when i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was
doing and and i [ __ ] had a
you know i i was awful
what do you mean on stage i got on stage
and did a scene with her in front of a
bunch of people on a showcase at al's
bar and i sucked
you you don't forget that you remember
this like i could tell i didn't even
know what the [ __ ] i was doing and i
swear to myself at that time i went like
that will never happen again so you
almost thought like i'm gonna quit
acting no no no no no i went boy you
didn't know what you're getting into you
didn't really realize how much you know
you weren't prepared you weren't you
were not prepared you don't know how to
prepare you don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're doing
you can't just [ __ ] wing it
wow you [ __ ] so you were just going
on natural talent you know i could just
do this based on like you know yeah and
i i'm just good enough
i don't even know if i was saying i was
good enough i was going like i'm just
gonna [ __ ] and keep going until somebody
says you can't do this anymore
really you know what i mean yeah
was was cameron one of those guys when
you're doing t2 was he one of the guys
who was like hey great job really great
job i love that he was he was always
that guy he was yes yes he was
yeah and and and you know i don't want
to gloss over the fact that uh i really
owe him a
i owed him
in my career i mean you know james
cameron is really the guy that uh saw
all that bundle of insecurity and you
know and all that stuff that i had going
on and said
you can [ __ ] do this
right he did say that you know when i i
read the script and i came into him it's
a long i'm not gonna we don't have
enough time to get into the whole
[ __ ] t2 thing and there's tons of
times i've talked about but you know
after i read the script which took like
five [ __ ] hours i walked in and i put
the thing down and then i
i can do this
then he
that's why you're here robert
that's what he said
that's why you're here
yeah and that that was pretty amazing
and that was it and i got the role
and that changed your life oh yeah gave
me my career
that one role gave me my career because
you were broke i had nothing
the money i'd made on die hard too i
bought a barber an engagement ring
that's still living at the hollywood
tire tower at franklin argo are you
serious yeah is that haunted that place
no
i thought it was haunted with
your ghosts my ghosts your ghosts